[Music]
the first step of every vintage is
cutting off
most of what happened last year
so that we are pruning away
what came before and planning for the
future
[Music]
the vine tells us what it needs to do
for the next year and we get to coax it
to the place we want it to be
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
wine is for me this intersection of so
many things that I'm interested in it
has a tremendous history there's a
significant amount of science and
chemistry biology that's interactive
that every year is not a new experiment
but every lesson from the years past
gets poured into the next vintage to try
and understand how to make the best out
of that vintage it's that perfect
marriage of Art and Science we just
spend all your time just crafting it
putting it together and then you just
set it free into the world we only get
one chance a year to make that wine from
that place as a unique object and every
year has its own challenges
foreign
[Music]
most wine makers are control freaks we
want things to be done a certain way
nature doesn't really follow those rules
from the first time you prune to the
first time you've gone out there and
seen a little bud you know the process
is going to react to that year's Mother
Nature we tend to have very strong
relationships with her because there's
only so much that you can do with
man-made inputs she's going to do
whatever she wants and you just have to
learn to go with the flow
it's a very peaceful relationship
I think acceptance is important you're
given what you're given make the best of
it when you learn to just let other
nature take its course and stress less I
find that
my wines tend to be a lot better because
I'm really holding that vintage for what
it actually is so we try to do as much
as we can and then you just kind of
shoot up the prayer and hope for the
best at some points I think I do have a
lot of rain dances Sun dances
occasionally do your rain dances you
know whatever you need to do you're
still farming and you know that is by
definition going to be crop shoot
oh here it goes it's a partnership but
in the end Mother Nature really has to
the final say
[Music]
if you're a Serial producer you can
usually go back to the market and find
grain from another location and still
produce you know your Wheaties or
whatever it is you're doing wine is from
somewhere and so if I lose the fruit out
of a Vineyard it's gone
and we have issues with frost Drive the
winner in 2008 we lost 90 of the crop
one shot
Frost gone
it's like getting a terrible childhood
disease where there's no coming back
from it
new plan things you get Frost at the
wrong time well you're putting new
plants in the ground the next year
because they're dead literally done uh
try again next year
[Music]
when to pick is really the most
important decision any wine maker makes
in any year that day
that's the decision you can't unmake one
of the great business plans is to make
white wine because you get to pick white
grapes before pressure comes along but
with red wine grapes you need this
maturity that comes with time and that
means you're hanging that fruit out at
the end of the season and something can
come along
[Music]
it's not often that we have seasons
we're not forced by heat or rain to pick
either a little bit before or a little
bit after when we really want the fruit
to come in in general you kind of find
yourself doing this this dance with
Mother Nature and really trying to
figure out in some Vineyards if you can
get the grapes as ripe as possible
before something comes in those first
few years if I look back on it now and
tape recorded myself I'd probably be
slapping myself
there are a number of phone calls about
rain and and all sorts of things and my
partner lovely wife said to me you can't
do anything about it just roll with it
[Music]
even though
so much of what a wine is is driven by
things that are in part outside of my
control
what's grown how it's grown where it's
grown who's growing it and the
environment of the year it grew in
particularly that's beyond my control in
2010 you had a factor which was a very
hot spell and in 2011 you had rain
so what does a winemaker do when those
things happen 11 specifically got a bad
rap because a lot of people did Panic
and they picked it green yeah and they
weren't ready and they couldn't you know
there's no way to fix that right I left
my Zinfandel on the vine and I let it go
through two storms my dad was not
thrilled with me at all and if you
embraced mother nature and you let
Mother Nature kind of do its thing it
worked and it worked phenomenally well
seeing the great wine makers they really
shine in those vintages I'll use every
tool every technique every idea to help
push the wine to the best they could
possibly be under those circumstances so
being flexible and understanding what
your options are at all times and how to
best achieve your goals and within an
ever-changing environment that really is
you know the issue of being a wine maker
you have to embrace why vintage is
important the same brand from the 2011
vintage to the 2013 they're going to be
different wines they're they're going to
be different flavor profiles every year
is different that's what blows me away
is every single year is different it's
definitely what keeps this job fresh is
that number one year is the same one
year might compare very similar to
another year but it might be like five
years ago I remember hearing people talk
about how the Vintage is in different
Napa don't matter like
are you crazy maybe they're not as
dramatic as they are in burgundy or
Bordeaux where you have these disaster
frames but we have cold Seasons we have
hot Seasons we have rain
so even though it's the same wine maker
the same Vineyard the same grower the
changes in vintage show different faces
of wine if everything was a commodity in
the wine industry that would be really
simple I'd just say that you know red
wines have this character and a Cabernet
always tastes like this in a Chardonnay
always tastes like that that's not what
it's about it's about the region they're
from and what makes those regions so
special
[Music]
you know we have this view of what a
winemaker does and he's out in the
vineyard and he's tasting his barrels
and he's looking at that and I may not
taste barrels for a week or two because
I'm too worried about when the next
shipment of barrels is coming and is my
glass coming on time and do I have a
bottling truck in the time and the labor
for Harvest or any number of other
things so we are running a five rings
for this driven by
many factors beyond our control one of
the other winemakers who lives not far
from us said
before he puts he calls this the cap and
gown the cap and the top being the Gown
he's made a thousand decisions that
affect that bottle of wine I don't know
if the number is right but it's the idea
how complicated it really is
I started working with Ron his property
is really a small Vineyard like a
Southwest facing solar panel on Howe
Mountain classical Mountain red volcanic
soils sitting on top of a rock cap so in
a few places is only 18 inches of
topsoil it really is a site that does a
very specific thing every year yes there
are some variations in the line but you
always know that it is from there it has
a voice and it sings
ah
it's late spring about a month after Bud
break and so we're getting into this
Grand period of growth that shoot was
half it's half that size two days ago
the flowers still have yet to set to
turn into berries we're sitting at this
time of year you've got six months of
decisions to make and then it's two
years in your Barrel absolutely with
more decisions to make another year in
the bottle with more decisions to make
exactly every choice you make has a
Cascade of effects that affect you three
years later or four years later because
you're affecting buds the following year
in the vineyard and we're one of the few
industries that actually take
the raw product of planting it in the
soil nurturing it up for three or four
years to become a Vineyard then we get a
season a year of Mother Nature to coax
this vintage to the very best that we
can and then we bottle this creation
that we've been working on for five
years and then we have to try to sell it
to start the cycle all over again and so
the relationship of the person who
hopefully is opening up that bottle is
really wired back to us that is that
direct connection back to a place and a
time and to people who are involved in
it
we're about to come through and remove
extra shoots from The Vineyard selecting
which
shoots we're going to leave
so we see in this little short shoot
here that there are two clusters that
will potentially become berries down the
road during that period of flowering if
we have really bad weather those flowers
will fail to turn into grapes we had a
frost that could destroy the whole
Vineyard I admit to being totally
neurotic during flowering two weeks for
me the best part of this whole project
has been understanding the role of
Mother Nature absolutely and she's the
boss and she wins and you have to take
hold of that and interpret it for us you
can't control it no so we're once again
we're subject to the whims of Mother
Nature and as a friend of mine said
sometimes nature is just a mother
end quote
[Music]
thank you
this is a first look at a at a 13 estate
cabernet from up here on Howell Mountain
which was a very fun vintage how at the
Moon
how Mountain the Knoll Vineyard Napa
Valley Cabernet Sauvignon
2013. it was a lot of the new wood
characters so great sort of spice
components red fruit cassis
some really nice Blackberry Bramble
characters underneath beautiful tannins
Rich structure
in the nose it's beautiful tobacco leaf
because Seas Palm Island's kind of
famous for the type of tannin that Inky
color there's also this like
hot rock notion you can really sit down
and you can smell a glass and you know
there's this Rutherford dust concept I
feel the same you know in Howe Mountain
that there's there's this different type
of dust that's up there I call it Moon
dust and it's really really quite
interesting when you're working on how
Mountain there's like this Stony
generality that comes through it's
really complementary to Big Reds and it
appears in my Zinfandel it appears here
in this Cabernet
part of the story is seeing that there
was actually somebody who did this there
was a person behind that bottle of wine
on the Shelf someone whose livelihood
who's training is to make that thing
we'd often forget that it's that it's
not necessarily an industrial product
it's a it's a crafted thing that someone
has poured their intention into silly me
but it never occurred to me that that
was an option I could do that thing and
so I'm a Consulting winemaker I help
many small Brands and some larger ones
with their projects I have a set of
skills I understand the business aspects
of wine I'm predominantly a scientist
and a biologist and a blender I'd
understand how to grow The Grapes how to
assemble the ones how to how to manage
that I can understand how the pieces go
together to make the wine that my
clients are interested in I don't own
any Vineyards I don't own a winery I
work at other people's wineries Arkansas
among them and that's what you get with
Consulting you get to be able to work
with different owners creating you know
perhaps different styles that they on or
different blends or whatnot but most
importantly you get to work with farming
in different areas of the valley which
is very cool
[Music]
we're at Hidden Ridge Vineyard high in
the mayakomas mountains between Napa and
Sonoma in the Sonoma County side it's
the end of spring we've just completed
the grand period of growth so the canopy
is about as tall as it's going to get in
the growing season
the flowers are setting to berries we
still have some canopy management to do
for guiding sunlight into those clusters
as they develop and ripen
what makes this spot unique is both the
extreme topography the Paris hillsides
where the vines are planted but also as
you can see right now this Breeze coming
in from The Petal in the Gap from the
Bodega Bay that moderates the climate
here provides for good warm days but
every afternoon we start to cool off
preserves natural acidity and fruit
flavors that make this a truly unique
site when you're up on a Hillside and
you have thinner soils and you have more
extremes this is very volcanic soil up
here this is very Rocky it's going to
create wines with a more significant
personality they're not the easiest
grapes to grow in the world they all
look like they're struggling and they've
got some attitude
um they're a little pissed places that
where the vine has some struggle to give
usually give wines of some distinction
that chiseled Hillside expression at
it's very bold it's very dark it's very
intricate and capable of finesse at the
same time
Napa and Sonoma are divided by the
mycommons range it starts with Mount
beader and then goes on to Spring
Mountain and diamond mountain the North
End
those mountains are important and I
think the people that live in those
mountains are important it's actually
one of the last holdouts of the Pirates
and the poets on the hill a bunch of
crazy people above mount beader it
really is a last Refuge of the radical
hippies we could call one side of the
mountains there nap Valley and one side
Sonoma but if you're living up in those
mountains and you're farming up in those
mountains you're connected to everybody
on both sides the ones that are made
from the myacomas range I think are more
of a family into itself than it is
specific to Napa or Sonoma
foreign
[Music]
California Legend was a California such
a great place to grow grapes that the
terroir didn't make any difference what
defines Napa as a great grape growing
region is its proximity to the San
Francisco Bay which you can see behind
me that cold body of water keeps the
Summers moderate keeps the nights cool
we might be 10 degrees cooler on the
ridge line than it is in the valley
floor which gives a unique character to
the grapes at this site there's a
concept we have in wine making called
terroir about the uniqueness of place
and how the Earth gives the character to
its wine and from a winemaker's
perspective at least from mine it's not
just the Earth it's the climate it's the
place that Those Grapes grew in how that
vine interprets its location and gives
its unique qualities to the wine that
comes from it it's the combination of
factors that make a place right so it's
geography geology client climate it's
the interaction of the variety and the
rootstock with its environment that
translate into the characteristics of
the grapes I grew up you know in two
different locations and it comes out
different even though the vine is
theoretically the same
when we started this most of the
vineyards in Napa were planted on axr
absolutely axar was a crazy rootstock
and didn't seem to make much difference
what the terroir was then when the axr
was wiped out by phylloxera all of a
sudden we learned oh my goodness the
terror makes tremendous too an enormous
amount of difference we have named
Vineyards within Napa Valley within
Sonoma County that are great for Pinot
Noir they're great for Cabernet
Sauvignon and I think we're continuing
to refine that so terroir does make an
enormous amount of difference I really
believe based on what I've seen the
changes in viticulture in the wine
business and in wine making that yes
style has evolved because of
consumerations and the scoring some but
the change with axr and then the change
of how we manage canopies were the
fundamental drivers in that difference
and it just so happened that the most
powerful sort of critics like the style
of wine that came from that I think this
evolution is a good thing and I think
the differences between Noma Napa and
all other parts of California will
continue to Define themselves
[Music]
I believe that Napa Valley in its
diversity of microclimate soils so on
and so forth there is so much diversity
in the tawar
a dark matter in my life
from each other and the wines couldn't
be more uniquely different there's a
certain structure and a certain textural
kind of perception on wines from
specific appellations I think every Ava
or appellation has its own signature
their own print on attributes of smell
taste and texture my difference in
ripeness a difference in acidity a
difference in soil you've got Stag's
Leap often being referred to as this
Iron Fist in a velvet clove where it's
just these silky tannins there's a there
there to the fruit and stag sleeve the
sort of softer tannins the kind of black
fruit that people can recognize very
readily stagsley District was one of the
first avas that really made an impact on
the international scene so I think it
has a historical importance and then you
might have something like bandwider or
Spring Mountain or Hell Mountain that
just has these intense mountain tenons
in this really robust structure with the
different kind of fruit pattern even
slightly romantic approach to terroir
that the people that make this place are
part of the terror war in some ways the
year and the people that make it
a few years ago when we were pushing
ripeness levels to an all-time high
level we were maybe dissipating that
concept of terroir but today we're kind
of pulling back and maybe reconnecting
with that you know for me as a sommelier
having that sense of place is a big deal
I want to know about this Vineyard and I
want to tell a story about that Vineyard
each individual location has its own
story that we try to capture in a bottle
I love the sense of tawar I love when
you can taste the soil taste the dirt
I've watched my grandfather do it for
years where you take the dirt and you
taste the dirt
and you see if you can see that actually
within the line and that's what's so
amazing about the Napa Valley is the the
difference in sites from valley floor to
Hell Mountain to Spring Mountain to
Oakville specifically it's great when
you can taste the wine and say wow that
came from Rutherford or hey that came
from Atlas Peak or diamond mountain for
us here it's to tell the story of this
little place in Stag's leave as
truthfully as we can and I think every
decision that I make I try to honor that
idea you're really looking for that
unique voice from that place what does
that place have to offer The Grapes that
are grown there and find that and
emphasize that particular characteristic
[Music]
thank you
it's got just this beautiful fragrance
of sweet spice candied fruit I get uh
spice notes and actually very very
pretty cherry in some ways this is a
truly classic wine more in the my comma
style than in the modern rubiso style
and it's got your signature in it you
always find this very deep fruit every
vintage we make what I've done is
increase the concentration of those of
those flavors mostly through farming and
then some through when I pick and how we
manage the wines there is a tendency in
certain parts of the world to make wines
that are so overblown that they're sexy
and they're lovely but there's no sense
of where it comes from but this land
requires the kind of style that I think
that you're you're expressing with it
the flavors that we're dealing with are
not ones that I'm bringing to the wine
they're from the place I really do think
that this wine could only come from here
that's real I meet people sometimes who
think that we're just making it up when
we say that sometimes people think it's
just marketing spin it's like no any
agricultural or Horticultural product
that you put a lot of care into like
coffee or chocolate it's going to have
incredible sense of place the problem on
this estate is anything that's like the
the terroirs are so many absolutely
rubiso is an incredibly complicated
property there's quite a bit of
diversity in aspect and soil soil depth
the same uplifted ancient sea bed that
are incarnarrows and are different from
other parts of Mount vitamin other parts
of my peter have this have the soil type
but mountvater is a mix of these ancient
seabeds and Volcanic uplift the form of
the mountain so the issue after years of
working there I think of our spot as
being a very warm Carneros Vineyard
Mountain Vineyard because of the cooling
winds off of the San Pablo Bay part of
the San Francisco Bay it's much cooler
than neighboring Vineyards that are
protected from that breeze quite a bit
cooler even than the town of Napa not
very far five minutes away the land
gives you what's possible from the place
certainly I leave that stylistic
handprint on the on the wines but wine
is one is one of the few exceptions
where you can trace its origin
to the location that it's from that it's
about somewhere and that it says about
something about the place that's from it
at its best some wine is just wine to
have today and not think much more about
it than it tastes good with dinner and
that's all and really that's fully
mine's main function is to is to
brighten your life and to have I feel
that way enjoy it let's not take it too
seriously but sometimes do rise to the
level of art where you want to
appreciate the thing for its
craftsmanship it's this it's a sense of
place it's origin it has a story to tell
even if you don't know the history of
the thing that just in tasting it it
brings something extra to the experience
for the original 150 years we were
trying to make French wine or we were
trying to be inspired by the Classics
wine is part of the way of living in
France and thanks to the appellation
system and to the history and now in
France we have very big wines very
prestigious wines that we kept the
traditional way of making them and that
maybe we'll talk a story to the people
when they will drink it
but once we got connected or comfortable
in our own skin so to speak we really
started making true expressions of of
California and of Napa Sonoma Russian
River but those differences are starting
to matter I have been accused of making
bordeaux-like wines from this property
and I wonder why I believe that Sonoma
and Napa are influencing the rest of the
world maybe more so than the rest of the
world is influencing Sonoma Napa at this
point in time
so in choosing a place for two
francophiles for two unifiles who with
great love for Bordeaux you chose the
perfect property to make that style of
wine beautiful those are that is the
kind of wine that this place makes if
they taste like that that's because
that's the way they taste not because
I'm trying to make them that way
[Music]
it's changed so much
often say that that when we first put
this in the bottle it was very closed
aromatically it was intensity but not a
lot of fruit flavor now it's perfumed
it's drinking nice it's really lovely I
mean it's still it's still really young
but it's incredibly Supple it has that
little spicy note that comes off the
hell Mountain Vineyards balance good
fine grain tannin you know you can feel
the tannins though because of the youth
but who knows it's beautiful tobacco
leaf because Seas red raspberry fresh
cigar box black currant red currant you
know all the beautiful flavors that you
would expect and smell and in a Cabernet
Sauvignon swirling the wine is really to
get air into the wine and make it smell
like something you really want to smell
what The Wine you know to get well the
wine smells like put your hand over the
top swivel around
and take a big whiff after that
smell and taste
if you swish the wine around in your
mouth again you're going to get more air
into what you need to cross more taste
buds really the other big trick and this
is a kind of a learned skill is the
slurp so you go with this you
foreign
most of our sense of taste is really our
nose and so slurping brain air through
the wine and pushing it back out makes
the wine explode in terms of flavors you
don't have to do that every time but to
get the most out of the experience
that's what you do
[Music]
got a nice nose it's got tart fruit just
the right amount of Earth flavor coming
after it a little cocoa on that kind of
has that whole Ebenezer Scrooge nose
some cherry in there too chocolate and
coffee and rassi really sweet tart
finish fruity is I think the expression
would be it smells like wine yeah I
don't know exactly
right I mean I mean it's like you're
supposed to enjoy
the wine the way you enjoy it we often
get caught up in a particular
nomenclature so that the Wine's
minerality and the acidity and its sweat
Stone and all that which is often what
the experience is that the Wine Drinker
is saying I I think it tastes like wet
rocks it doesn't taste like wet rocks
but the smell of the rain on a gravel
driveway has a smell to it and if you
smell that in one that's what we're
talking about for somebody with a Davis
background we all took in novel's class
who told us we need to come to an
agreement on what this language means so
that we're when we say Blackberry we
know what Blackberry means right
needless to say that language will not
become the measure by which people
describe wine people are going to get
creative the sense of smell is tied
directly into our emotions and
um and into our into our memories
they're going to talk about their
grandmother's pantry and they're going
to talk about oh Christmas at you know
Uncle Joe's or whatever references they
have it evokes those things we smelling
wine you smell Blackberry you smell
um
when I get that sort of uh sugar cookie
clove my grandfather had a taste
descriptor called foxy where the heck
that terminology came from idea that the
wine was a little bit more tannic and
that it was cloying and kind of almost
like you have sandpaper on the front of
your teeth and your lips kind of
sticking to it all of those things are
real but if you're a novice and you know
nothing about wine you say this smells
like wet latex paint on the inside of a
bicycle tire if it really does smell
like this
then that's what it smells like to you
not this one I have smelled those both
of those things in wine you need to
follow your intuition first and listen
to your gut before listening to what
everyone else says you sip it and
instead of looking at the other person
for validation you just say oh yeah
strong blackberry leaf all it is is a
statement it doesn't mean you're a snob
or anything it just means that this
particular human smells blackberry leaf
so if you taste chocolate or saddle or
your ex-boyfriend's dirty socks that's
the thing that's there so don't worry
about ever using using the language
that best describes the wine to you and
that's the right language
the last major developmental change is
version it's when the grapes go from
hard green berries to colored flavorful
berries it's point in time when the
bunches have closed in the berries have
sized up cell division stops but cell
enlargement continues and cell softening
happens so we see color flavor all the
changes leading into ripeness the seeds
are ripe enough for the plants to grow
and we spread so the vine is now
deciding to make the fruit around them
attractive to be scattered about by
Birds by Animals by people and it's that
attractive characters the flavors the
intensity of the sugars that we're after
as mine
very end of erasion we cut off those
clusters that are developmentally behind
they'll be adding unripe flavors to what
is mostly a ripe Vineyard we typically
drop between two and five percent of the
crop at that final green thinning I
never understood that there's a deadline
where if it isn't turned purple you know
it's not going to ripen because as an
end date where it's going to get picked
exactly because of the weather again
here comes Mother Nature into the
decision not all Vineyards require it
and
some Vineyards have
to just work a little bit harder and
that's where that dropping fruit really
comes into play almost every year this
comes down to a battle of the vineyard
team versus the winemaker team although
as the owner I don't want it to be a
versus situation but it ends up being
that
that's one of the biggest battles we
have is that it's the the fruit they see
on the ground but it's not the fruit on
the ground that matters it's a fruit
that's left on the vine
[Music]
The Vineyard team will always want
the crop to be as huge as possible
because that's a sign of abundance and
you know look we did a great job
and I think the wine side is always
trying to tempt that down there's a cost
for Quality right and who do you want to
be is the first question any any wine
maker wants to ask we're trying to make
beautiful expression of this site and
the only way to do that is through
restricting the yield and managing the
canopy
so it's this balance every year whatever
it takes to put something right in the
bottle is what we do here and you know
when your Vine can't handle a larger
crop load given what the conditions were
for that year and it's just part of what
has to be done what we'll do is we'll
aggressively drop fruit prior to Verizon
because this crop will actually overload
itself so I'm out there cutting fruit
off and crying and cutting more fruit
off and crying but understanding at the
end that's what lets you love what's in
that bottle yep there's definitely stuff
that we're going to be cutting off
beforehand like this I don't like it
when it's all raisins it's not painful
it's you know it's it's just active
decision making and necessary
um for my grandfather it was he used to
make us go behind and pick up all the
fruit and then we'd have to crush it
um and it was that was painful
[Music]
at the end of the day if it makes you
know better quality wine
I'll sacrifice a little I posted it the
first year we did it and called it
owner's lament on Facebook because it
has beautiful clusters on the ground
and you realize what's left is what
again you're affecting the decision to
put behind that label
[Music]
there is a vibrancy that happens during
Harvest it really there's a period of
time it's about three months long when
the fruit comes in it really is the most
exciting time of the year for for me and
this adrenaline rush that you get it's a
frenzy it's the time of year that we
anticipate the most because we are going
forward into the next vintage can't wait
for fruit to come and yet at the same
time we dread it because
there's so much riding on it for the
next year often my easiest time of year
is what most people consider the hardest
it's harvest it's what we like to joke
our slowest people I have one job to
make the best wine a hundred times in a
row for three months that's what I do
you have this nine month build up every
single year and to get to that that end
goal which essentially isn't the end
goal but just the beginning of bringing
the fruits in is really kind of what
it's all about
[Music]
I think those few weeks leading up to
harvest that time
is to me the most special everything up
to that point you do before you make
your picking decision is in trying to
make the grapes as ready as possible to
make the wines that you hope to make out
of those certain blocks
once the decision is made to plant a
variety of rootstock on a site what
Drive style from that Vineyard is how
it's grown and when it's picked style
really is impacted by the winemaker's
decision on things that will affect the
Aesthetics of that wine right when to
pick are you a riper picker a less riper
picker I might pick two weeks later in a
Vineyard than another wine maker the
wine that I make will be different it
will still tell you something about the
places it's from how it was grown how it
was managed but the flavor profile will
change so from raspberry to Blackberry
to Blueberry to prune so I'm so happy
that I'm not here all the time during a
harvest and you probably are too because
implicitly when you get to the end of
the Harvest period you start tasting The
Grapes you know they taste quite ripe
well you know those are good the rain is
coming I said come on Tim go and pick
them and you're always saying no no no
you got to wait about a couple of weeks
or something there's a whole group of
new wine maker years knew as of the last
30 years that pick just by taste when I
taste a specific thing
coincides with what I'm wanting we make
our picking decisions based on on
walking the blocks tasting the fruit and
when it tastes right for what my goal is
the wine at the end that's when I decide
to pick I think that's my favorite thing
on the planet is walking Vineyards
tasting fruit getting close to that
moment when you know the fruit's optimal
we're looking for the specific
depth of character
beyond the sweetness so there's a
spiciness
there's a richness I'm looking at
dimpling which is a huge thing
for me this is my indication that I'm
almost ready to pick as well as I'm
tasting the flavors I'll receive bricks
later today last week the bricks were at
25 1 with the heat I'm assuming that
this will probably put me at 26.
foreign
[Music]
eries will pick entirely based on
chemistry when the when there's a
certain amount of sugar in the grapes if
it was a high degree of sugar you just
picked it then and it was like you
already hit your your numbers just pick
it Dad back in the 80s and 90s he would
walk through this Vineyard and we would
do detailed chemical analysis on all
this and working with you
with your own method which I feel is
just as technical but the technical
aspect is built into the sort of
intuitive aspect all those different
factors kind of play in and over the
years I've I've Focus Less on the
science and use it as as a reference but
really go more on my intuition now the
chemistry is a pretty blunt instrument
in terms of trying to understand what's
happening at Harvest Time and there are
things it tells you but the things that
you can tell by taste or more both the
same things and in addition plus to
certain points and harvest numbers don't
really mean anything
we definitely look at numbers but my
decision to pick is really
um it's based on on taste when it's we
get close to harvest every single day
taste taste taste making sure the
chemistry is right but it's still the
flavor we definitely started evaluating
solely based on taste and flavors solely
on taste for me yep so
when you're picking based on Flavor not
on chemistry
you have to taste a lot of fruit
after you taste enough grapes you can
tell when they're perfectly ripe there
is a light bulb that goes off the
acidity is just speaking the right way
to me in my mouth the texture and the
tannins are speaking to me what I want
specifically I want bright flavors for
me when I walk through the Vineyards I'm
tasting the grapes and I'm looking for
you know those dark fruits those black
cherries current is something I'm really
after and then obviously going back to
the winery and looking at the numbers
and and seeing where the bricks levels
at the for the sweet enough it's been
it's been developing it's enough bricks
it's around 25 26 bricks enough to make
wine but the question is how's the taste
flavors are edging into Blackberry uh
sort of nice ripe flavors the tannins
are still a little bit edgy I try to get
it before it tastes raisiny and it
there's like a fine line
it's about the freshness of the fruit to
me I really like to pick fruit when it
still has some fruit Integrity so I
don't like you know I don't like raisins
not too many anyway a little bit it's
good for complexity but not too much I
remember as a kid I was an A's fan I
used to chew on my baseball glove I
remember that leather tanniny taste when
the grapes are just past ripe they start
to taste like that we want them on the
fresher side of ripeness I'm by no means
am I looking for an over ripeness I
don't go after that pruney character
because I do want the acidity and the
grapes to come forth as well there's a
juiciness to it there's a floral aspect
and then there's a lot of pepper in it
which is totally crazy to think that you
can taste all that in a grape but it
really expresses itself when it becomes
wine as well and then that usually that
Plum characteristic it's always present
right when I'm about to pit and it has
to be very releaseable in the skins and
you can actually with your own eyes you
can see and feel the color the
anthocyanins that are in scrape skins
I'm looking to see the color extract so
that's a good indication I'm gonna have
a good color here and if those are
giving and the flavors are there and you
know the seeds are matured which is
another critical part color of the seeds
is where you find full
maturity of a grape those seeds get
brown and you look at it and you just
know ground seeds I'm looking for a
little less of the pulp sticking to it
another indicator of ripeness is the
tissue how the tissues are evolving the
still gelton coat the around the seeds
and as the seeds ripen they change color
how did we get all those ones it tasted
like stewed vegetables it's because the
interior of that grape was not developed
enough those seeds have to mature to a
sort of a Nutty crunchiness versus a
green harsh Tenon hitting this kind of
balance point where you're at this full
ripeness where you can really kind of
chew down on the skins and the seeds and
not be left with anything green or
bitter and then trying to translate that
through into the finished wines when all
of those three factors fall into place
healthy fruit the release of color and
the ripeness of the fruit and the seeds
itself is when I decide to pick
nice and nutty
really good
almost there about a week away
that decision is the most difficult one
that I make the one that I lose sleep
over more than anything else is is it
time could I have gotten another day or
did I go to you know you're trying to go
as far as you can without going too far
you're most connected to the ground at
that point and you know the decision
that you're about to make will impact
um what you're going to have in the
bottle the great wine maker wine grower
dichotomy comes up immediately at that
point because well we really don't want
to take up that little piece of land and
pick it in 10 picks you know but over
here can't you do it too right exactly
no no what no you can't just pick in
Broad swaths we pick in these little
micro batches this kind of Vineyard is I
mean it's part of our soul we connected
with this land in a very personal way to
get a sense of where the ripeness starts
slower ripening section do you see the
differences as you walk through a
Vineyard from one side to the other or
variations in the topography
what I taste in the vineyard
translates into the wine at the end
it really is fundamentally the flavor of
the grapes that translates that
transforms into the wine if the grapes
don't taste good the wine won't right so
the limit of quality of any wine is the
fruit that it comes from and so wine is
a shadow of the vineyard
foreign
[Music]
one of the better years we've had and
quite a few so we've got a little more
dehydration than we might normally have
that's because this is such a dry
location and that's what makes our wine
so distinctive in terms of the intensity
of flavors and Aromas because these
Skins are so thick they're packed with
flavor and aromatic chemicals we've got
great tannins great color the flavors
are really really popped you know that
perfect Ripe Tomato that perfect ripe
Apple the perfect ripe Cherry well it's
the perfect ripe great
grapes for wine are sometimes a little
wrinkly they're not the most beautiful
thing but they taste beautiful and
that's what we're after
most winemakers have this experience
during Harvest that we're walking
through the vineyard tasting fruit
thinking
do I have forgotten what ripe fruit
tastes like have I forgotten what it's
like is this this doesn't seem right to
me but it's been you know the timing
things look about right and then two
days later the fruit changes oh of
course that's what I'm waiting for now
we're there now it's time to pick
it's good it's really good
really good we've had great weather for
the last two weeks we've been able to
hang it as long as we wanted you can see
the canopy starting to turn yellow it's
fall it's really started to come on to
us and it's time to bring the grapes in
[Music]
come on what do you think are they ready
ready to go
[Music]
thank you
it's harvest I've decided to pick so I
call the vineyard manager get me a crew
or two Crews we can get so many tons off
that day it'll be delivered to the
winery by 10 a.m or 11 A.M or 1 p.m
um you know what the point Rose at the
North End of H that we're going to leave
for later let's take those now that's
the perfect life of a winemaker I'm
standing in one Vineyard talking to a
Vineyard manager about another pick
that's going on that this happens again
and again we pick most of our Vineyards
because many of them are Hillside
Vineyards you can't run machines through
by hand a man can pick about a ton of
fruit in about six hours depending on
the vineyard it's the hardest work that
you could possibly imagine I've done it
it's it's a beast and do it fast and
they do it clean
of great respect for the people who do
who do that work once you've made that
picking decision there's really not a
whole lot that you can add to it but
there's a whole lot that you can lose
from not treating the fruit properly
there's always a bunch of leaf matter in
the picks so we try to get as much of
that out as early as we can because as
soon as these dry leaves go through the
disclaimer they just get obliterated a
million little pieces and then
everything else does still put that
through the Sorting table but
uh as much as we can do now is probably
helpful
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
when you bring the fruit in you really
want to see that it's given all the
attention that you can give it so we
take every care to make sure that we
de-stem it and handle the fruit properly
and get it into tankless as softly as
possible I use what's called custom
Crush wineries so I don't have my own
Winery where I bring fruit to I bring
fruit to a winery whose business it is
to crush my wine or someone else's wine
that sort of thing so I would arrive at
the winery with the fruit
and the fruit gets processed so we have
forklifts to pick them up and definitely
not lay the fruit out and there's people
who are picking out the extra leaves
that might have gotten through you can
see the ladies and Tim sorting right
there in the the berries just sort of
travel along that table anything that's
smaller than the grates in the bottom of
the table falls through his waist
um anything that's blown off in from the
air knife that we have at the very end
of the table also uh gets thrown into a
waistband and the wine business they
called MOA material other than grapes
snakes beer cans all kinds of fun stuff
even perfect looking little blueberries
fall down into the uh the sump and in
the auger auger right there and get
pumped through up into a sink we become
almost obsessive in all the little
minutiae details that can influence the
way we just stem it the way we handle
the fruit coming in temperatures the
fermentation process
if it's white wine it gets thrown direct
to press so the whole clusters get
dumped into the press and it's a great
big machine with a balloon inside that
presses against the grapes and squeezes
the juice up simple as that
that gets run down to a tank maybe the
barrels and fermented and becomes white
wine so we brought in some Pinot Gris
grapes this morning from Oak Knoll
district and we're using a technique
called whole cluster fermentation so
we've got the intern team doing here is
they're foot stomping the grapes meaning
we're going to leave all the all the
stems and everything in there during the
fermentation you get more tannins from
the stems and you get a little bit of
potassium so it changes your pH and
changes your mouth feel and we're just
trying to make kind of an interesting
component here for a blend of ours
so after we're finished here with a
stomping in a minute we're going to
basically take these bins and transfer
them to either fermentation bins or one
of these beautiful cocho pesto
terracotta tanks that we have
[Music]
foreign
it's only the best fruit mix to the tank
and I'm just a worker yeah and with 13
especially with summary and I being able
to get on the Sorting line for the first
time and being able to physically at the
end affect every single grape that's
going into that final process is the
culmination of all those walks up and
down this hill and I think you just
smile you just you have to be happy
about it otherwise you couldn't do it
because you're farming yeah this is
fresh fruit that came in day before
yesterday it uh it's still just juice
sitting in the bins The Next Step will
be to take them out of this cold room
let it warm up a little bit and we'll
actually inoculate with these and that
yeast will convert the sugar and the
grapes into alcohol and carbon dioxide
the CO2 just goes off into the air be
picked up by the plants for next year's
wines the alcohol stays in the wine and
that's one of the reasons why we drink
wine
red wine made with red grapes has most
red grapes have clear juice if I wanted
to make a white wine from Merlot I would
rather than run through the crusher and
stick it in a big vat and let it soak on
its skins I would throw it in the press
and press that juice away from the Skins
the same day it was picked the juice
would be gray or clear lighter than
Chardonnay so blonde Noir the sparkling
wine or champagne is Pinot Noir but it's
white
from the same grapes that are in this
bin I make a rose
you can see that the Flesh of the grape
is clear I pick the fruit goes into a
press it sits for a couple of hours gets
slightly pink we press it off that gets
fermented without the Skins stays Pink
goes to the bottle pink that same fruit
two to three weeks in this bin will come
out dark red and this will make a
delicious medium body or red wine
so this is Merlot that's been fermenting
it's out in the sunshine to warm up it
was in the cold I want to get this
fermentation going get it up into the 80
to 80 degrees Fahrenheit so out in the
sunshine today beautiful day in Napa
Valley and when it gets to get some heat
going on so here we are berries I think
CO2 from the East is pushing the berries
up forming a cap and so they'll come
through and push that cap back into the
wine get that color tannin flavor out of
the skins and so they come and do that
two maybe three times a day depending on
where you are in the fermentation there
are some wineries that call this
methodology the ancient method which is
punch it down by hand we're almost
through fermentation but it'll keep
pushing this cap up next I don't know
four or five days and we'll wait for it
Falls in until the cap drops will be
seeing the industry and
I'm here to make sure it smells good and
see how it tastes on the way
this is a tank of Hidden Ridge Cabernet
Sauvignon it's just started fermentation
it's been in here about six days it's
gonna change the temperature settings
it's pretty
cool right now 68 degrees it's just
getting going these are set up with an
automatic pop overs here you see there's
a little air pump to open this valve the
wine runs through pumps over the top
through an irrigator just like a punch
down we did look by hand in the bins but
with a irrigator device on top you can
get that juice over those dark skins get
the flavor come out
let me get into like diabetic shock
drinking these they're very sweet and
very ripe it's about 25 sugar a little
more than 25 sugar so it's pancake syrup
we call it and then we'll get going
fermenting turning that um
sugar and alcohol nice thing about the
process is when it comes to the winery
well it doesn't suddenly transmogrify
into something else it just translates
into the flavors within the wine so
right now I'm getting
um BlackBerry
it's like a red cassis
red raspberry
and it's about halfway to being wine
um
right now the acidity is a little higher
than it will be at the end because the
most red wine goes through a malactic
fermentation it softens the acid so the
acid's a little popped a little high
right now that will come down balance
out but it's Tans aren't overboard
flavors are brilliant you can see this
one's quite a bit foamier coming out
the yeast are working away and the heat
of that fermentation is taking the color
and flavor out of the Skins it's a clean
is it happy and this is very happy
[Music]
it's 20 bucks
this one's um
done fermenting it's wine but the wine
is still sieving on the grapes
and still trying to get more texture
flavor uh tannin out of these
it'll probably be here for another week
or two based completely on how it tastes
and my view is it's not quite done yet
foreign
[Music]
decision is when to press That's the
final step where you say okay I've we've
taken everything we can out of the Skins
there's no nowhere else this wine is
going to go that's going to make it
bitter and that's when we'll make that
pressing decision pressing off is all
about palette it's tasting so once
something is on extended maceration I'm
tasting it every other day trying to
find that balance of tannins and Seed
tannin and all of it until I feel like
it's a complete wine and that dictates
my pressing decision how hard and how
long determine the quality of the juice
that comes out of the press when you're
free running it and you're pressing it I
mean you're just taking it off the side
and just and you you basically you stand
at the Press when you chase the change
right and you watch when the flavors
change in the juice
but there was a point we say Free Run
let me get a little bit richer a little
bit richer right stop
done because I was getting too tanked
and it was standing there the whole time
that's what our day is just watching the
Press we're here today um pressing off
um a tank of our 2013 Cabernet Sauvignon
from the estate this is a basket press
so it's basically a very high-tech
replica of an old school basket press to
where these used to be cranked down by
hand with a screw press
yeah
this is a hydraulic basket press so
you've got a motor powering the Piston
um that pushes this plate down and and
just squeezes all of the loss good good
wine out of the skins for us this
process is basically the last step of
harvest the wines have completely
fermented so it's no longer grape juice
it's it's Rich ocean Cabernet what we do
is we drain off all the wine out of the
tanks and then we throw all the grape
skins into this basket here and and
press it out
[Music]
foreign
so what I do at this stage is I will
make sure it smells good and then we
taste it
[Music]
and we typically spit it out because
we're doing this all day long
um
so what we're tasting for is is the
tannins in the mouthfeel and see how
this wine is really shaping out because
it is so young but it's important at
this stage to really pay attention while
pressing so you don't press it too hard
and over extract some of the the drying
cannons to make sure that you have a
nice balanced wine
the Free Run is pretty soft it's got a
lot of nice kind of rounded tenons but
this press one just has all the heart
and soul it's got all the mid palette
and all the Finish we're making the
Chardonnay we have uh both the Free Run
and the Light press is one fraction at
about 20 that's hard pressed it's been a
separate creature its entire life from
the from the day of press or just Hank
into its own a little hard pressed yeah
you want some of the hard presses it has
some of these richer qualities to it uh
and a change in between palette so we'll
look at blending some of this back into
our media piece to add more
texture
absolutely backbone and that's when you
can really get all of those beautiful
just tendon and structure that you're
hoping for and actually it's softness
and roundness it actually ends up being
rounder and richer than the more pure
mineral driven free run it's a pretty
small part of the uh of the final Blend
but it makes a huge difference
[Music]
you should be very happy
foreign
[Music]
and once we've finally made that pricing
decision it's not like we we go on
vacation we walk away
we Barrow down as quick as we can and we
we really try to make sure we protect
the wine as much as possible
[Music]
foreign
so I use Cooperage as an element of
complexity and spice I am a true
believer that the barrel is a vehicle of
maturity by no means do I use it as a
vehicle of flavor it really just depends
on the tannin structure and the tannin
development that I actually get that is
what's going to be taming your tannin
that's what's going to be bringing your
wine into complexity and aging it so
that neutral Oak actually tames it down
a little bit and allows for that bright
fruit to actually show through for our
fruit Oak shouldn't be Central it just
supports the fruit there's an evolution
that happens you bring flavor out of the
barrels into the wine but in this Barrel
now for a couple of months so within a
week they start changing sure your wood
your alcohol your extraction everything
over time as it ages has to go in
parallel and I go back to a vehicle of
maturity when a barrel is brand new the
pores of the barrels are very open very
fresh for my how mountain lion lines
they all get 100 new friend joke because
the tannins can actually hold and I
actually think it softens the seed
tannins that come out of the wine you
know those caramelized sugars are
available from the bending of the wood
and the bending of the barrel they're
available but more importantly is that
breathing of that virgin wood where an
older Barrel pores of the barrels have
already been sort of clogged with the
solids and the tartrates of the wine so
the breathability is a lot less what
I've been working out is really
fine-tuning you know what works best
with the fruit of each block back to the
whole point of being a balance and so
you have that more massive wine you need
more input from all the characters in
the Earth
[Music]
we get to the bottling still preserving
all of those magical things that we were
able to taste in The Vineyards and taste
in the fermenters and and translate all
of that to that end product
[Music]
thank you
2013 was a absolutely remarkable vintage
in that we had really brilliant weather
modest crop loads it was a very very dry
summer and dry growing season the
beginning of the drought cycle so that
the lines were
still in Balance but but fighting for
their for the growth we love drought
conditions drought conditions give us
small berries a lot of concentration the
yields were
high enough to be commercially viable
but low enough to concentrate flavors
for Quality our yields in the vineyard
were slightly down which also typically
means that the quality is going to be up
and I think we knew early on just even
in tasting the fruit that 13 was going
to be pretty special in terms of
intensity and antenna structure more
definition more detail more freshness
more more and more and you made a
comment to me with 2013 fruit that that
may be the best fruit you've tasted in I
think utos from well over a decade back
before 2004. yes the quality of the
fruit in 13 was undeniable
[Music]
thank you
2013 to us was one of those years that
neurotic Ronnie didn't have to be
calling Tim what about the rain what
about this because in the early years
neurotic's a good word
we had perfect weather conditions in
that season we weren't driven by any
pressures at the Harvest I mean even the
11 when the storm came in and lasted for
two weeks and you know all of the
wineries were out here crushing for 24 7
and everybody was fighting over space
and it was horrible so to see 13 come in
and kind of let everybody relax the pace
was a perfect pace for winemakers and I
think they did an extremely good job of
mastering that all through Harvest I'm
watching the weather thing there's a
huge storm coming in seven days the end
of harvest will be when that storm comes
but it never came
people were holding their breath because
it was just too good to be true rain is
the Enemy at the wrong time and it just
didn't rain we just kept pushing it out
and pushing it out based on it's getting
better it's tasting better there's
Goldilocks here I've heard people call
it because it was it was it wasn't too
hot it wasn't too cold it was perfect
you know
somebody related it to an Easy Bake Oven
as a vintage it's hot at the right time
it's cool at the right time it rains
when it's supposed to it's dry when it's
supposed to and you can literally
pick whenever you want to let us make
the decision the way we really wanted to
make those decisions and that that's a
fairly rare thing or truly and whenever
you're given the chance for the grapes
to have a nice mellow even ripening
season I believe that you get more
balance and more texture more complexity
into the grapes itself we were able to
bring in this beautiful Harvest with
Incredible uniform ripeness and by being
able to let the fruit hang without fear
of raisining or crop failure we really
were able to let the fruit get as ripe
as we needed it to wanted it to to have
the ability to really call your pick and
decide you know based on flavor and
based on history in this Vineyard based
on the end end goal I'm going to pick it
you as the the Vintner winemaker get to
make those decisions as opposed to
Mother Nature basically making your
decisions for you we really were able to
say now now I want it it made better
wine in 2013.
look in the mirror nobody's ball put
your room
[Music]
the last stage for any wine is it's
released to the public
style the wines that I make were
typically two years in Barrel or just
about two years in barrel and then a
year in Bottle they need that time to
evolve to develop the birthing process
takes it's not so much damaging it's
unsettling to the wine and that takes
another six months to a year to recover
from and so the fall three years after
the wine was first made is when we
released them to the public I think
that's the beginning of when they start
to taste good
[Music]
never tasted this Reserve so here here
we go oh yeah hope this lives up to all
my expectations
don't tell me if it doesn't no tell me
tell me if it doesn't I'd love to hear
your your uh
yeah here here
but um
complex of mocha I get sort of like
grilled herb does Mountain herbs those
are things that you just cannot copy on
Valley floors you know and they're from
Chaparral they are from forest nearby
Wild Sage all kinds of things yeah
people don't understand that the fact
that the leaves up on the mountains or
pine needles make an impact of course
they have to they go down and become
part of the soil too and so they really
have that kind of special touch and I
think that this Vineyard really has that
impact in so many different ways there
are trees and parts of this Vineyard and
you can taste it there's just layers of
different kinds of things you say that
Blackberry Cherry with more layers of
herbs it almost reminds me a little bit
of allspice
you know where you have clove and you
have all these different factors that
kind of come together as one as soon as
you smell this you've realized there is
something distinctive and special going
on there's a smell I'm looking for Wow
even
more stuff going on than the last one
it's a good expression yeah
[Laughter]
just the right amount of Earth flavor
coming after it that's probably the Two
Buck Chuck because that is the one for
me
laughs
[Music]
it was clear to me that we had something
that was dramatic and powerful and and
found for Robert Parker the one thing he
loves is complex wines with a lot of
muscle that's a tendency of his this has
all of that when I made that blend it
was there really were two pieces that
played off each other and then there
were a couple of other elements that
added Dimension and complexity I think
that appreciation of the mountain really
shows in here too no one can replicate
this flavor and I think that if Parker
gave that a lot of credit I give it the
same credit because it is a very very
unique wine getting in the Perfect Score
puts you in a fairly exclusive club and
it's nice to be a member of that club
but I'm not driven by that how can I say
this the point system
I personally have a problem with it you
know they're going to be there right
people like numbers they want validation
it's never going to go away love it to
go away certainly in the marketplace of
wine and the selling of wine it's an
important feature commercially is
important yeah I mean uh scores so long
scores so long people want to know that
there's a third party Arbiter that said
that wine is that good I think wine
ratings are a very important tool for
for consumers wine scores are an
important way to communicate to a large
number of people scores do help to sell
the wine my only point is they don't
tell us anything about the actual wine
in the bottle Hugh Johnson once said
well what do these people do do they
score their relatives do they score
their spouses is this how they go about
life like how do you measure you know
something like that how do you describe
your best friend you might be a great
guy you give him a score well my best
friend is a 90-point guy right but what
does that tell us about him red hair is
he tall is he skinny consumers I think
expect that because it's a numerical
value that it's an absolute value rather
than reflective of the tastes of the
reviewer
I do believe that the score and the
process is very much about the score ER
and you kind of develop a relationship
with those those people because some
reviewers have very directed distinctive
preferences and if you don't like that
style of wine it might be their 100
point wine right but it's your 90 point
wine at best just remember it's one
pallet usually or maybe a few pellets
that are putting a number on a wine and
we're all plumbed a little bit
differently so there's a very relative
meaning to that so I don't take scores
very seriously everyone's different
their sense of taste is different and
remember wine is a living thing it's so
important to remember that it is a
living thing and it really goes through
these waves one day it's going to taste
like X the next day it might be this the
greatest Wines in the world you know
they taste differently they go through
these ups and downs swings absolutely
the fact of the matter is a score can
never tell the whole tale of a wine and
that that makes me sad about people who
just look at scores I just wish there
was more of a conversation about wine
rather than a rating of wine I'm always
impressed when the reviewer is able to
put a number and a description together
that delivers to me when I taste and I
say okay I can I can follow that and I
think those are the type of reviewers
that I prefer hey I'm fine with the with
the wine criticism I say Bring It On
anytime you make any
creative output in this world it will be
criticized and I think we have to you
know be open to that it's never going to
go away and that's okay you should never
live by scores because you'll die by
scores right so don't don't make that
your goal don't let it break you
certainly as a small little company
we've never been driven by
the scoring mentality we have never
collectively made a wine to Pander no
never no no we pandatory to our to our
buyers sure not to or not to them and
sometimes it aligns yeah no I mean
happily however we've never we've never
we've never doctored aligned to you know
the the infamous Parker Barrel right no
never done that
the thing that makes you strive for
Perfection is the work itself not
necessarily the critical claim a claim
that may or may not come by the way I do
appreciate good scores when they come in
of course of course I love it so that
probably sounds like well he's full of
crappies you know he's contradicting
himself
this is a exceptional example of the
2013 vintage style class and character
that really exemplifies that Vineyard
itself
foreign
[Music]
what makes a great vintage is not a
single event it's a massively
multivariate event that has a single
solution which is the wine you have in
front of you people need to remember and
understand that the amount of things
that had to go right
for a bottle of wine to deliver the
pleasure that it does or pretty
remarkable and that's a winemaker
working in tandem with Mother Nature
[Music]
every bottle tells the story of the year
it came from and the people who made it
when we taste the 2013s and we taste the
passion and the signature of these wine
makers you can really find out a lot
about you know why that brand is so good
or why that site is so good it's because
the winemaker was able to capture that
in liquid form it's pretty transparent
you can try to do as much as you can to
it but in the end you're putting one
bottle in front of a person or one glass
even and it's got to tell them
everything they want to know in that one
sip
[Music]
handing someone here's what we did
together this year I hope you enjoy that
I hope brings some pleasure to your life
with the people of our size it's love in
the bottle and you're hoping that when
someone
opens a bottle of the wine and looks at
it and it goes from the label to the
cork to the top that they're getting as
some piece of pleasure in their life the
best part about being a winemaker is the
end user I mean there's nothing more fun
than being out and you run into someone
and they go
two research I love your wines I want
rubiso wines to be delicious and lovely
for people that's simply what I want I
want them to feel the passion and the
love and know that there is that
Personal Touch you know it is me you
know that's out there
um doing the work and and making sure
that you know my clients wines are being
made to the utmost Perfection I think
one of my biggest hopes with the wines
that we make is that they kind of taste
the passion and really taste all of the
effort that we've we've put into making
these wines every time someone opens a
bottle I just hope that they can take so
much energy and time and care that we
put into it if anything wine is meant to
be enjoyed with people that you love and
you're just hoping someone's going to
open up that bottle taste it have a
smile on their face have a good time
want to share it with their friends
which is what this is all about because
wine is social it is the same thing in
France like in America and Upper Valley
or Italy or even Australia New Zealand
everybody meets around the bottle of
wine and the important thing is to share
it with people you love and when the
company is good the wine is always good
whining in so many ways is the unique
generator of conviviality you're sharing
and experience and it often brings out
conversation and in moderation a really
good time the most memorable bottles
that I've had have been a result of
people I've had it with the meal I've
had with it or the situation I've been
in there's not a Holy Grail bottle but
you know the sideways bottle or you it's
so precious that you never want to drink
it and you end up drinking it alone
that's not the point that misses the
whole point you know when you go to a
great dinner and it's all about the
camaraderie and how great wines you know
get you into conversations and how you
tell a story about how you've seen this
Vineyard and you've been there it makes
people love it that much more it's part
of what the dream of Napa is for many
people and
the the silent part behind all of that
is this is family farming
but there's something so irresistibly
romantic about Vineyards and the Allure
of the wine and the intoxication of it
and the transformation you go through
when you drink a glass of good wine as
opposed to bad wine when someone sends
you a note about it even or writes
something it's just amazing it makes you
do this absolutely yeah absolutely yeah
and it pushes you to through the next
winter into the next year to start all
over again I think my dream always is
that people have an emotional response
to to the ones that we make a smile a
happiness a look and then you know
you've done it you know that you've
affected someone's time on on this Earth
just like I experienced in the first few
wines that made me really think this is
more than a beverage I want people to go
to stop and go oh my God the Aesthetics
of this are so moving
um just like a painting would move them
or a piece of music so I want people to
have an emotional response I've said
that I think before like I want to make
people weep
what I want people to have as a a sense
that these things were crafted with care
we put all of our heart and soul and
personality into these bottles each wine
is unique to the client and yet at the
same time you can tell the Fingerprints
of the winemaking team through it
drinking some of the 13s now they're
just babies but they're incredible and
you just know that they're going to keep
going for for years they're evolving
beautifully and they're really starting
just starting to sing right now I think
they're starting to open up and be
approachable but I love 13 love love
love we're gonna make some friends with
them they were what we expected we were
very optimistic about 12
um
great fruit quality wonderful definition
excellent wine
you know best of all worlds big and
beautiful
how could 13 be better
it was 13 was perhaps the best vintage
that I've had a chance to make wine in a
decade yeah
the nicest vintage since 2004 of the
year we started together it was a great
vintage if you were a wine maker in Napa
Valley in 2013 and you made anything
less than an outstanding wine you need a
different line of work because it was
just that easy the season was
uh you know perfect and absolutely
Dynamic vintage that we will look back
on and I can't wait to taste 2013
Vintage Wines 20 years from now they're
agers their 20-year you know put them
down and seller for 20 25 years and
they're they're going to be gorgeous in
my 12 vintages that I've done 13 is the
one that stood out
where the stars kind of lined up it's
the definition the detail and the uh the
little things that make a great vintage
and 13 had all of it
I think will be seen as a classic
vintage because it has the power and the
texture to age for decades here's to a
great 13 vintage well that is the 13
vintage in a nutshell except in liquid
form exactly
[Music]
thank you
to the wine Angel up there he has
bestowed something nice on us you've
helped us to be better yeah I look at
the history and so I kind of hug you I
just want to thank you he made a big big
difference in us thank you George it's
um it's been a pleasure and cheers
[Music]
foreign
so where are we Tim we are at a winery
we're doing some custom Crush I've got
my own tanks in their space
and I'm just we're at the very beginning
of a fermentation and I'm making sure
the temperatures settings are where I
want them it's a classic Cabernet and
there's no juice coming out of that tank
that's awesome it's because it's empty
[Laughter]
[Music]
expert winemaker doing his thing
to be this good at this
[Music]
we're just putting your glass and do
that
and if you're in Australia I think you
do this
really nice
[Music]
Shameless Alfred Hitchcock moment
the outtakes are the part of the real oh
yeah ready
[Music]
something yeah
so you're a winemaker and you're
drinking gin and tonic uh
you know there are there are days when
when wine tastes like work it's an old
saying in Napa it takes a lot of more a
lot of wine country it takes a lot of
beer to make wine
um can't drink beer so uh gin and tonic
this is fun these are great wines too
good job
I can sense of beer coming off
nicely done
[Laughter]
yeah that's what I've been telling you
in fact viruses and all that break down
in water
they dissolve so what you're saying is
that it's good to keep good health just
to drink a lot of wine yes absolutely
having enough Sunshine having a small
crop are Central to to building a wine
that that has the power to age and power
and texture
good job cheers you guys Cheers Cheers
cheers
[Music]
foreign